I greet you warmly my name
is dr walter ziegler
i wrote
this book series great thinkers in 60
minutes for you and my students
simply because it
is important to me to once again present the core ideas of the most important
philosophers in the world in a clear
and understandable way
philosophy is yes  something really
wonderful she asks the most important
questions in life why am
i here what does it all mean how
does society work the
history of mankind
and if you look at everything
from the stone age and the simplest
beginnings to
today, the  ask where does it
all go where does the story end and
above all what can or should the
individual person do in their life there
is something like a task and if so what does it consist of?
the great philosophers
give the answer the problem or you
could also say  the fascinating and
exciting thing is that these answers are
very different
that's why in the book series big
thinkers in 60 minutes i tried to present the
core idea of the respective think
r using the most important quote
and asked the question what use is th
s idea today, for s
ciety but also for us perso
ally, i.e. for our daily life
all thinkers have asked the
question what is it that holds the world
together
at its core, for example with plato it is the
idea of the good, i.e. the opening of our soul
o the good and that we learn to se
with the inner eye with
arx it is of course the produ
tion conditions  the work
the way we
work and produce personally but also as a society
this
work shapes our whole life when,
for example
, the indians of south america or the germans used to build a field together and shared the harvest
they felt very
different from one  today's factory worker clerk
or manag  he in
capitalism being determines the consciousness so
marx with freud it is not the work
but the libido i.e. the sexuality
and beyond that the drive energy that
we either live out suppress or
sublimate with hegel life is
about the world spirit
unfolding  my title always brings me to higher levels
with world spirit but not
some god watching how
we toil here on earth but
our own development
i.e. man is first an infant then a child
an adolescent then adult and
also the history of mankind
unfolds from the simplest beginnings
on and on and steers towards a great
ultimate goal that
is the world spirit with
self-development of history with
nietzsche the decisive factor in life is of course the will to
power with habermas language
i.e. the development of communicative reason
rather than through language and
the desire inherent in it  according to  nding
the world keeps growing together like this habermas
that is his great vision
i could explain it to many other
philosophers because basically
everyone has a phenomenon from
which he tries to understand the whole world
that can just be the work the
sexuality the language  the will
to power and interestingly
the philosophers not only explain the world
from their perspective but also tell
us what could be
our personal task in life within the framework of this world explanation
you see i
try to introduce
the core idea of the respective philo
opher to you in each individual volume and
Yes, a question I'm often asked
is which philosopher should
you
start with if you're interested in philosophy? Well, I think it doesn't really matter in the end, because
each of these thinkers has undoubtedly struck a
spark out of the crystal of truth
.
I only have a lot left for them
to wish pleasure